[Music]
positions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for years
[Music]
seasons
[Music]
you know
come true
[Music]
seasons of time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's weird that's that just created
a short circuit in my brain because I'm
used to hearing that back through
headphones yeah I never do in case you
know it's performative art I don't do
the slurp on my own time I do it on the
show
and it was weird my brain well this is
not how it's supposed to happen look
good with you look who's back Ahoy Dave
Landau is here of course Gerald is here
uh the whole crew is here a little bit
of a different setup just so you know
they were going to do the January 6th
hearing today not on January 6th for
those who are confused they moved it uh
this was a hearing to be to be clear for
people who are confused it was going to
take place in Washington DC yeah but
there's a hurricane in Florida right oh
so it's not happening now really yes
it's changed it's science as to why I
have no idea I can guess they didn't
want to lose a spotlight yes right the
January 6th the case there is so paper
thin that they know a hurricane and of
course our thoughts prayers go out to
everyone affected by this hurricane I
hope that you've gotten to safety uh
they know that that would knock them out
of the trends because it's not something
that people really are invested in it's
not something people really care about
they want you to care about it so we've
decided since we did all the work anyway
the leg work as you can see with all of
this prep we're gonna do a January 6th
live stream anyway and perhaps the
medicine the what what medicine for the
this is the problem too don't say
anything look at me because I can't hear
you I'm on my headphones oh you didn't
just condemn not the Jews in the bank
thing again no no no no no no no no no
no no no that's off camera right
so uh the hashtag is lwc Gen 6 lwc gn6
please if you guys can use it get it
trending that would be helpful because
we want to make sure that everyone is
informed now before they host their
January 6th sham hearing not really a
trial and uh we have a promo code which
we are still making available right now
for the next 24 hours is it 24 hours uh
well I think it's kind of a little bit
longer than that but okay it's for two
days it's a gen six you get 20 off uh
mug club letterscrediter.com and we will
be taking if you're on Mud Club right
now all of your questions regarding
January 6th so if you see the questions
popping up we don't do super chats the
only questions we ever take are through
mug club and we'll be doing that
throughout the day so so for the safety
of everybody here though I think we're
actually closer to the hurricane than
they are in DC should we postpone just
to be safe hey you don't know that we're
like a thousand miles away I forgot I
forgot we have a Dr Noah over here yeah
right it's like about you saying a guy
got six states away from me he's gonna
shoot me right now Sebastian Cheryl
doesn't Outback building an ark yes
with a few pieces of plywood on it but
it would look like the uh it would look
like The Gallows for Mike Pence which
we'll get to it's going never mind
just stop building I said decent man not
[ __ ] this is uh I'm mixing my
biblical analogies so
before we move on here look this is I I
wanna we were preparing for this
um this is what you can expect from
January 6th and this is why it's
important to counterbalance it
they want all of you and we can't
address this right now if you want to
see uh want to see in real time what
happened go back to our election stream
was it 12 hours 15 hours I don't
remember it was very very long and you
can see what took place in real time as
we watched the votes roll in as states
were very very likely going for Donald
Trump uh versus when they changed live
in real time so at that point in time
you need to remember that everyone was
confused everyone thought that something
was awry
and they want you to think that that
never happened now wherever you line up
on what happened on whether it was all
mail-in voting and then you know 97
absentee ballots going one way we're not
going to talk about that because that of
course would result in all of us getting
banned which again is the purpose they
can host a January 6th hearing and keep
in mind this is not a trial
and remove any voices uh who might
actually speak out against it under the
guise of well you're questioning the
election well they're trying to condemn
people who showed up and peacefully
protested in Washington DC as as
terrorists why because you questioned
the election and if people say well hold
on a second I don't know we we were
protesting peacefully or we actually did
feel as though there needed to be for
example uh some regulations oh they are
what do you mean regulations they broke
the constitution in Pennsylvania when
you were saying hey we think they should
follow their own Constitution they want
to say no no that's questioning the
election you have to be removed to give
you an extreme example to make a point
and it's not a real example Carrie Lake
was on our show but three four weeks ago
something like that yeah an election
that she won in Arizona a primary she's
very likely going to be the governor of
Arizona she said hey I want you to know
exactly what has taken place and there
were some voting anomalies what she said
she said I don't even know if I can say
what she said you can go and watch it on
Rumble you can go and watch it on my
clip she said I want to make sure that
there's a transparent process so I know
exactly by how many votes I won that's
someone who would have every incentive
to take the win and this is why I think
the Kerry Lake thing is so important
they try to say with Donald Trump it's
sour grapes therefore it's subverting
democracy
what about someone who won
saying I want to make sure that I won
and I want you all to trust that I won
and I did so uh fairly even-handedly
they removed that
I don't I can't think of anything that
would be more pro-democracy it would
strengthen democracy more matter of fact
that's that's you didn't ever hear of
politicians doing that your advisors
will tell you take the win and shut up
yeah absolutely just move on and you got
to remember on Election night we had
been hearing all kinds of stories about
how the the mail-in system was fraught
with challenges right challenges but
don't challenge it they hated the joy
right the person who's in charge of the
the postal service right they hated him
and they said he was doing things to
make it to where votes wouldn't get cast
they wouldn't be counted there was
reports released before then that it's
really really difficult to do male
invaliding because sometimes people
don't get their ballots they don't get
them back on time sometimes they get
lost in the mail there's been
Republicans for this week yeah exactly
so that's what we had in our heads like
this is a very difficult system to trust
and then we see the totals I did it live
on air I was like Donald Trump's
actually outperforming Donald Trump in
2016 in these states right how is it
possible that he's going to lose and at
the time that's what I said and if you
even address now we we have to tread so
so lightly because a lot of seconds
other people were talking about the joy
said there are challenges if you say
there are challenges presented that we
need to remedy you're questioning the
election therefore you are to be uh
Associated and Guilty by association
with the January 6th insurrectionist so
the goal of the January 6th hearing and
the reason it's not a trial where you
you don't get to cross-examine right you
don't get to call your own Witnesses
which is important because they've made
statements that would be considered
potentially perjury in a court of law
we'll get to admissible yes we'll get to
Hutchinson in a second yes uh stories
about Donald Trump jerking the wheel and
Secret Service agents saying no no I was
there that never happened I would
testify under oath they were not going
to be there today and the reason is they
want you all to be guilty by association
with the insurrectionist if you so much
as even think that we should strengthen
election Integrity or even have voter ID
that's the goal of this yeah and to show
you how much of a stretcher is the
stretch there is is uh they were they
had some footage that we were not able
to get a hold of about from Roger Stone
yeah they want to bring in Steve Bannon
they want to say look these people said
don't concede the election and Donald
Trump worked with them at some point
therefore that's what was happening
Donald Trump hasn't worked with Roger
Stone in a very long time yeah and he
booted Steve Bannon to the curb
unceremoniously and he said he's a loser
effectively that's what Donald Trump
said about Steve Bannon he said he was
booted for a reason and he's not coming
back they want you to think because
Steve Bannon said something on his radio
show that that must mean that's what
Donald Trump was doing they want you to
believe because Roger Stone said
something trying to talk big to his
friends that must mean that Donald Trump
wanted to hang Mike Pence therefore if
you support Donald Trump we've seen the
rhetoric since then right Maga is a
threat to American democracy that's you
just to be clear that's you and it's
important that you don't allow yourself
to be gaslit because we've had this
happen yeah where we go wait hold on a
second that did happen right did I dream
that no no I didn't dream what happened
in Wayne County while we were covering
it live no wait a second I didn't dream
what was happening at that point in time
they want you to feel that way the goal
is to divide and conquer and they do it
through lies so that's what I think the
macro goal is for January 6th we're
calling balls and Strikes here please
once they actually get to their hearing
yeah I assume during a temp when there's
a tempered climate
uh there's no other news period watch it
and tell us if we got most of this right
what what do you expect here Joe I mean
when they do have their hearing I expect
nothing more than just innuendo right
they they kicked off the two Republicans
that would have pushed back the hardest
I think I've got the names down here so
it was Jim Banks and Jim Jordan right
people that would have pushed back and
what they did is put the most milk toast
Republicans possible who are both on
their way out one by choice and one
thank God not by choice she got her butt
kicked Liz Cheney and then Adam
kinzinger saying that oh we have
Republicans as a co-chair this is a
bipartisan deal right no it's not you're
not trying to get at anything if you are
trying to get it information you would
have sworn people in you would have
brought in people who said the other the
other view you would have had a debate
about it you would have had Republicans
on there people that you hate people
that are going to interrupt you and say
no this wasn't what you thought it was
and then people that were going to agree
with you and then you would let the
American people decide or you would
refer it to the Department of Justice
that didn't happen what you did is
stretched it out as long as you could so
that you could affect midterm elections
and that's it and if you're a good
lawyer the strongest witness you can
cause a witness who would have every
incentive to testify for the other side
and flip him right that's what they
would want to do
if they believed what they said or they
don't yeah or maybe a witness who
actually witnessed things that's a key
that key word there being witness that's
in the name I thought that was part of
the deal you would think so Hutchinson
we're a little bit hardly anything we're
a little bit murky on the rule book and
this remember during election night this
is before you were here and you were
doing your own stream and I remember we
called in to you when Michigan when they
called in local news Wayne County for uh
Donald Trump yeah they said Trump won
and then some some Shenanigans happened
is what I like to call it what you mean
is democracy I'm sorry it happened in
the dead of night I'm sorry more voters
came uh and voted around 2 A.M and
that's counted well they sent out they
sent attributes through their Red Wagon
right there was a cooler filled with
good news yes sorry you mispronounced
camera equation
camera yes I don't know what to I can
say yes there was a January 6th is my
Christmas yes
well when they quelled the riots you'll
be visited by three spirits of YouTube
suspensions yes that's what he's
supposed to say each one wearing a
strike yeah speaking of which uh AOC
said she did almost die that day and I
was in Punta Gorda two weeks ago where
the hurricane is right now so I also
know what it's like to almost die well
that's because you drank the tap water
though too unrelated that's true yes
AOC takes her piece that tax Band so
let's go through what I anticipate being
right now CNN is wall-to-wall coverage
of the uh of the hurricane this is
exactly why
think about that if it's something that
is that urgent that democracy is under
threat yeah you don't say well it's
either it's either we save democracy or
we cover the hurricane
which by the way there's nothing you can
do about a hurricane CNN like it's
happening it's you're just there now and
hopefully everyone everyone has already
evacuated hopefully but there's no
others a guy just walked by in a
Hawaiian shirt just now yeah that's a
French Canadian Who's down there yeah
hold on for dear life and he's like you
want to come to our hurricane party he's
just like can I get to my apartment
please
in a banana hammock oh man they're not
doing the mai tai anymore the happy hour
is [ __ ] man parking lots are empty
parking lots are empty it's like well we
do have parking garages for one with a
case of hail yes
oh so it's windy huh yeah 25 miles an
hour so far in this place so let me walk
through that almost blew off this is
hell yeah how is this girl's baseball
cap still on well she's gingerly holding
it yes
just her index finger and thumb that's a
hat tip that's not even a holding it
these guys become very performative on
in these I mean and singing in the rain
at least she does the full right the
full yeah head on the head I want to
hear the the her hands off the hat now
it's back on no it's back well she
thinks she's back on camera yeah she was
like I can take it oh we're still
rolling the guy's like and I barely able
to stand and there's like two people
she doesn't even have a wind filter on
that microphone it's not even one guy's
like look out for that puddle your shoes
might get its head wet you don't get
your socks moist now to be clear of
course it's a horrible hurricane and of
course yeah and we raised a bunch of
money when it was in Texas for Hurricane
Harvey and we hope that you are all safe
the point is news isn't real nothing is
real as far as it relates to the media
So speaking of which let's let's try and
present the strongest arguments okay
January 6th and again we'll be taking
your questions the goal here is
it's tough to keep track of the timeline
we were doing prep last night I spent a
few hours going and I'm going oh that's
right I forgot about this oh the numbers
changed oh that's right I forgot that
Liz Cheney said this so it's hard to
keep track we want to build a timeline
here so you can remember all of it first
let me build the timeline and then we'll
go through what we anticipate to be the
uh the truth and the claims uh where's
the time on page three okay all right
hold on that's Roger Stone that guy's
weird yeah I've interviewed him a couple
times I've got the timeline okay so at
12 p.m right Trump his speech started
okay uh the rally as it were then at one
you have the initial wave of protesters
who uh some of them broke through the
barriers at the Capitol some of them
were invited in uh then you have it two
protesters broke into the capitol then
you have a 224. Donald Trump tweeted
that Pence didn't have the courage to do
what he needed to do that's what they
want to try and hang their head on
because he must have been encouraging an
Insurrection we'll get to that then you
have a 238 Trump tweets urging people to
remain peaceful so not even 20 minutes
after he said that Mike Pence doesn't
have the courage to do what needs to be
done
whether you agree with it or not he said
by be peaceful and before that he
already said make your voices heard
peacefully yeah just to be clear so two
times on two separate occasions they
have a 3 pm rioters they broke into the
Senate shame uh Chambers I only want to
use the term rioters okay these people
who were there these Hooligans these
vandals that's really what they were
you're talking about trespassing a
misdemeanor not people who should be
held without trial people were just
there right yeah uh 336 Donald Trump
called the National Guard and at 417 he
again told people to go home so this
happens relatively quickly
there were no deaths aside from one lady
uh Babbitt Ashley Babbitt who was trying
to get into the capitol was shot by
Capitol Police there were no other
deaths initially we heard right two then
we heard five then we heard seven then
we heard five the answer is zero aside
from Ashley Babbitt who should not have
been shot even if she shouldn't have
been there in the capital she should not
have been shot
because these are lies that were
existing
at different periods in in time
throughout this timeline okay at
different periods throughout this
timeline there were different lies and
different numbers so what do I
anticipate to be some of their claims
okay well first let's get to the Roger
Stone and Steve Bannon thing this is
these are the new Bombshells bomb shows
okay Roger Stone I think we have a clip
then they had exclusive footage
reiterating what this clip already sort
of includes but they were saying he said
it in a different way they were trying
to say that Roger Stone at one point
well obviously what the Donald Trump
advisor said that you should not concede
the election therefore Donald Trump
tried to fuel a violent Insurrection we
don't have their clip but there's
nothing exclusive about it because
here's Roger Stone saying it to anyone
who would listen at any point in time
all right this other clip shows Roger
Stone employing the people in his orbit
how important it is to claim Trump's
Victory no matter what on Election night
here it is
awesome let's just hope we're
celebrating I suspect it'll be I really
do suspect that it would still be up in
the air
when that happens the key thing to do is
to claim victory possession is nine
tenths of law no we want it for you
sorry over you're wrong [ __ ] you
hold on hold on telling people in his
orbit all three people that happened to
be about on Roger Stone at that moment
right in t-shirts he said if it's still
up in the air you claim victory right
were they stealing his car
I don't even know how he's stealing his
hair pieces I don't think he didn't know
him he just came out he's like hey
you're you're uh human beings with a
pulse yeah I don't know if you know this
I know Donald Trump
you look like three peacocking
Floridians yes
what an idiot so he's a [ __ ] I just
stretch to show that and he has not
worked in an official capacity with
Donald Trump for a very long time you
can even see when he gives interviews
when he would give interviews like Alex
Jones or other it would say you know
have you spoken with Donald Trump
recently would say well not recently but
I am in the know no he's not
that's a hard passion I just can't even
I don't get how the dots are even
connected right well they're trying as
hard as they can to tie unsavory
characters to being in Donald Trump's
order to telling him that he should do
these things and that's of course why he
did these things I get that but it
that's that clip would be like ah not
really yeah right yeah and by the way do
you know when he was fired by Donald
Trump do you mean a while ago right 2015
yeah I was gonna say 2015. and when he
would say yeah you know I do talk with
Donald Trump Donald Trump said that's
[ __ ] okay we have it from Washington
Post and Yahoo I think you have overlay
Q where he denied being in contact with
stone on multiple occasions now you may
say he was lying fine just say that you
think Donald Trump is lying about the
fact that he fired him officially on the
record in 2015 and he has said that he
has not been speaking with him you can
say Donald Trump is lying don't say that
he's a trusted advisor and he had
anything to do with the election or how
Donald Trump was behaving
that's the issue I don't have an issue
with people having an opinion I have an
issue with people lying that brings us
now to Steve Bannon they said they were
going to bring and by the way someone
there said this was going to be more
sweeping oh that's right Adam Schiff Mr
Mackey and then you have a committee
chair Benny Thompson said that this
hearing today would include more
substantial footage of what occurred and
significant witness testimony that we
haven't used in other hearings which
must mean any witness testimony right
that would be that would be helpful and
and why why did you wait so long I'm
really curious why you guys have taken
almost an entire year to get to right
the committee was planning on playing
clips of Steve Bannon ah okay
so Steve Bannon has gone on his radio
show or is a Syria whatever is a
satellite show yes talking about Donald
Trump again claiming that he's close
with Donald Trump claiming Charisma
power yes exactly
you miss you mispronounced liver spot oh
I'm sorry yes I forget the two yes
Donald Trump in 2018 as it relates to
Bannon he said Steve Bannon has nothing
to do with me or my presidency when he
was fired he not only lost his job he
lost his mind
Steve was just he was the staffer who
worked for me after I had already won
the nomination by defeating 17
candidates often described as the most
talented field ever assembled in the
Republican Party pause right there that
is so Donald Trump a completely
unrelated fact that he's like and by the
way the very best field ever in I won
Steve Madden is an idiot he's [ __ ]
and I beat the best ever dry your own
conclusion folks he's a [ __ ] and I also
this is also a problem with Donald Trump
as he says the most talented field ever
it's like well you call them Mr
smallhands of low energy well it's why
nothing he says even on paper you're
like you can't refute it you're like no
no he said that for sure
sounds like him here's something else he
said about Steve Bannon and again the
committee today the hearing was going to
be about how Roger Stone and Steve
Bannon the most trusted Confidant of
Donald Trump helped Stoke in
Insurrection they were complicit here's
another quote about Steve Bannon from
Donald Trump Steve pretends to be at war
with the media which he calls the
opposition party yet he spent his time
at the White House leaking false
information to the media to make himself
seem far more important than he was
it is the only thing he does well
yeah
Steve was rarely in a one-on-one meeting
with me and only pretends to have had
influence to fool a few few people with
no access and no clue whom he helped
write phony books
now maybe you like Steve Bannon the
point is Donald Trump doesn't yeah
really doesn't
he was gentler on Dr foul he was gentler
on fauci yes absolutely oh my gosh
he so thoroughly destroys you when he
doesn't like you what are we at with
Stevie lost his mind was incompetent the
only thing he
think he was lying and League
time with me because I didn't like him
and he wrote phony books
what more do we need
he's never around me he made me
uncomfortable and I fired him
two years before the election in 2020.
do you have any idea how hard it is to
fire someone in DC it's not even a state
and it's not an at-will state you have
to have cars and folks I had it we had a
lot everyone else tells me you had so
much cause I would say I didn't have all
that they said you had all the cars the
best cause
and then he lost his mind said where is
your mind Bannon oh where is your
mindset
and his book sucked yeah yeah and his
books are phony it sounds like a parting
shot yeah don't buy his books it's the
only income he has don't help him and
his dad killed JFK yep so uh uh
people tell me I would never say that
they say oh his wife she's such a fat
cow that's what they say to me could you
believe that's what they say to me
that's what people say
not easy on the ice that's what they
tell me you know you've you've heard of
a tall glass of water she is really a
rocks glass filled with with puddle mud
with Mexican tap water they told me they
said I said don't say that they said
she's Mexican taco can you believe it
folks
and I'm not talking topic you don't want
to near your mouth
so is there I mean come on these are the
two people that you have you know
breaking ground shattering news that you
have to cancel because of a hurricane
he's never been trusted by anybody no
and then you have Roger Stone who's been
I mean didn't they raid his house a
couple times they did and again it's
just to make an example of them yes
the storm yeah here comes the story of
the hurricane I hear that Ted Cruz's
wife is playing they say she's playing
plain Jane GI Jade could do push-ups
beat the beat the sergeant at the end of
that movie
he would do that too he would go down
rabbit yes randomly she she bit the side
at the end of the movie I said there's
no I said there's no way she's going to
beat the sergeant but she did she beat
the surgeon in hand-to-hand combat not a
lot of GI Jane's could do that folks
lwc gen sixth we have the promo code is
Jan 6th where you get 20 off my club
let's go through some of these uh videos
can you say this really yeah yeah all of
you chat uh people in mug club right
that's only reserved for my club send in
your questions about January 6 things
that we can answer obviously don't ask
us if Hugo Chavez invaded any voting
machines on Election night or anything
like that but send your chats in we
would love to talk with you when we do
go to mug Club later on yes and uh as
much as we appreciate him uh we don't
need 19 chats per second from Mike
Lindell that's true yeah this is my chat
I used to use their chat then I created
my own chat I got it made from Egyptian
cotton it's the best chapters ever been
and I'll guarantee you 30 days or your
chat back I used to do much less crack
yes
I just like I think Mike I like Mike
Lindell he's nice unfortunately this
muddied the waters where there was
enough when you were discussing the
election constitutions within the states
and then just stuff you can't prove with
the Dominion voting machine anyway well
then the pillow yeah well that's not my
favorite pillow it's filled up with it's
not the best I'm sorry they're the best
packing peanuts if you are high on crack
for 10 days and you need to sleep good
pillow yes it's better than the
cardboard box I used to use to you I
said there's got to be a better way it's
a good place to rest your knees to get
more crack
[Laughter]
he really has been clean for a long time
take it personally he knows
yeah actually a little aside he was done
he wanted to sponsor the show did he and
it was just we didn't have the time and
I said like I will I don't like my
pillow but I bought like 15. and I want
to support him and I said we will do it
as long as we can say
I hate this pillow and you should buy
like 50 anyway okay that sounds like a
good campaign
I was like you maybe could buy it like
in like for like a guest room like if
you hate your guests send it to someone
you don't like yes Christmas presents
for people you don't talk too much lump
of coal yes
oh I just asked father Christmas I wanna
I wanna my pillow in my stockings
by the chimney with Craig
okay all right so we have that again and
by the way hit the like button please
share this is something that of course
that you will not show on YouTube and by
the way Russell Brand is going over to
rumble he had something suspended
because he discussed Ivermectin a video
I don't know if it was a stream
suspended geez Mr Brandt don't apologize
yeah that would be my that would be my
advice to miss do not apologize ever
ever with the exception being that you
think you've done something wrong that
could actually cause damage don't
apologize just to appease them because
they will tighten the screws tighten the
screws tighten the screws and they're
going to ban you anyway so yeah he's
opened up a lot lately I've really liked
it yeah I'd much prefer him to back I
mean back in the day he was a communist
yeah and they well and they're going
after him hard right because they don't
like X commies who now say oh wait a
second I was wrong about that yeah uh
all right so let's we have the claim
truth so let's go through what we expect
their claims to be here's a claim that
uh we expect them uh to make at one of
these streams and again really all they
had that they claimed was new was Steve
Bannon Roger Stone hopefully we've
addressed that so Liz Cheney said that
for example there were tens of thousands
of protesters assaulted on the capitol I
believe this was the last hearing some
elected Republic
president Trump's decision to summon
tens of thousands of supporters to
Washington
and knowing that they were angry and
knowing that many were armed instruct
them to march to the Capitol
show plane
you said his wife listen to his speech
at all right he did not instruct them he
said hey I hear you guys are going to
the Capitol to make your voices heard
peacefully right just because her dad
caused 911 doesn't mean we have to give
her a hard time oh and see that's that's
what he would say I would say Dave you
can't do something you can't say he
caused 911 but that's what he says do
you believe and you know what he really
knows so folks maybe he knows maybe you
didn't know I'm sorry if you've gotten
things right before a lot of things
right I don't know but maybe he knows
I'm sorry pondered
so here's the truth here's the truth out
of the 80 000 people who attended all
the references are available right now
you can just follow along with the
bouncing [ __ ] lottery.com 80 000
attended only about 2 000 people entered
the building and by the way many of them
were invited we'll never know the number
of people but you've seen the videos
many of them were invited in yeah they
didn't storm anything waved him waved in
and I don't know how you charge those
people with a crime no I have no idea
and especially when the hearings first
started happening they were actually
just bringing this stuff up on the floor
right saying these people came and he's
like hey why don't you play the video
where the police officers open the door
and say come on in and they're like okay
guys we're able to go in and just be
peaceful the Q Anon Shaman even said we
must be peaceful yeah well then he broke
into uh Pelosi's office he's an idiot
look not everything was a loss
I'm not I'm not saying he's not doing
too much time but maybe a little just
for the half just a little he obvious ly
wasn't
overthrow the government
video
he was filming it yeah there was no
reason to be threatened by that oh wow
oh is he out
I had a feeling I don't think okay
he's still way too into this I know I I
really wish he would drop it taking your
motorist Hall whoa hey don't drink from
the bottle clean on Shaman
just you know go out they have their
Scotch out grab a scotch glass on Iron
Man yeah I appreciate it you guys lost
weight though Qing that's good for him
took the bottle with you and go to that
Barney and Fred men's club yeah yes the
Water Buffalo lodge
I wish because I wish kazoo had popped
up before the Insurrection like you
shouldn't go into the capitals
they invited us in
oh it's a trick yeah now pedal your car
yes with your feet
foreign
meanwhile they're teaching their their
young boy Bam Bam to commit domestic
abuse he's just beating the hell yeah
that's your mother yeah well
that's not how you communicate no you
gave him a bat
idea it's not like a pla like a wiffle
ball bat it's a it's a stone bat yeah
you gave him
[Laughter]
a giant whittled rock that being said I
did give one of my uh my twins a
blackjack
well sure oh wow I have mine a butterfly
knife for his first birthday that was he
learned the tricks no it's great I mean
he hurt himself yeah I know well you
know you don't need all five fingers you
don't need both your eyes either here's
another claim that we expect them to
make and by this I mean they made it
they're gonna try and double down on it
and again you cannot present opposing
evidence that is what's most important
to keep in mind here if you want to get
to the truth we have a process it's the
same thing you know I really want as a
guest in the show George Foreman I think
if you've not seen his testimony about
his near-death experience it's it's
unbelievable he's been a preacher for a
very long time he came back because he
wanted to support his congregation just
recently two women came out and claimed
that he committed sexual assault against
them 40 something years ago in the early
1970s and none of it adds up and the
statute of limitations has changed in
California the point here though is
there's a process remember with the me
too issues sure believe some people but
you need to have a process if you're
going to determine that a crime was
committed none of this would hold up
under scrutiny that's why they're having
a hearing they're having their sham
committee uh and not allowing
cross-examination not allowing other
evidence to be presented so this is very
similar with a lot of the cases
regarding the election let them say oh
they were dismissed no evidence was
allowed to be admitted and this is what
Donald Trump has talked about that in
many instances the game is rigged if
it's political and the person doesn't
like you sometimes you don't end up with
due process it's an unfortunate reality
but it is a reality and this is where we
could find some common ground rather
than saying it's black white as far as
the judicial system it's about the
elites and power and those who don't
have that power because it can it can
happen to anyone black white and
honestly usually happens to people who
are speaking out against Power right now
I think would be hard to argue that the
consolidate nation of power as it
relates to Washington DC including the
White House all of media all of big Tech
all of the entertainment industry is
very very far left if you speak out
against that power you will be silenced
we see it not only with us you see it
not only with future governor of Arizona
Kerry Lake and of course president
Donald Trump you see with people like
Russell Brandt you see it with people
like Jordan Peterson
that's what it is it's not a black white
thing it's not even a rich poor thing
it's a power and Powerless thing so uh
the next claim that you can probably
expect them to make and Cheney just made
that but we have another clip that
Donald Trump encouraged people to attack
the capital that's the claim they are
making now we're going to hear it from
the rioters themselves Skrillex not
objection I include in the record a
video presentation
you know I had supported Trump all that
time uh I did believe you know that the
election was being stolen
um and Trump asked us to come he
personally asked for us to come to DC
that day and I thought for everything
he's done did he tell you to bring the
helmet
yeah I'll do it we're gonna walk down
Discord yes yeah
did you call President Trump mentioning
going to the capital during his speech
oh yeah so that's one of my
disappointments he said he was going to
go and go with us that he was going to
be there yeah I love that guy in the
helmet Donald Trump called me personally
yes he said I want you I want to see you
in your stupid [ __ ] Starship
Troopers helmet down at the Capitol my
day won't be complete until I see you in
a leather [ __ ] helmet take your bike
helmet paint it green yes
I want every last Schwinn and Jaffa on
your head where's your chin strap oh
good you got it he invited you to a
rally he didn't invite you to break that
guy got a mass mail mass email that was
out saying hey rally for a rally for
Donald Trump and he's like oh well you
know what I'm gonna have this Frame like
it's a letter from the president it's
not really an invitation it's just a
rally you're allowed to go to right on
public property right yes I mean it's
cute that you want to think we're
invited did you RSVP and it came back in
the mail
hear us repeat on his ballot yelling at
his wife like where did you put the
envelope where I send this back which
envelope
the one from a Mr Donald Trump you're
not coming Deborah ring a bell no plus
one
Peter plus two
plus two two seats like Kevin Smith on
Delta Airlines it's sad bring someone
else Bannon so they say Trump encouraged
rioters okay here's the truth that they
will not present and will not be allowed
to be presented uh he clearly told the
protesters to be peaceful here's one
example we're gonna walk down and I'll
be there with you we're going to walk
down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but I think right here we're going to
walk down to the Capitol the capital
and we're going to cheer on
our brave senators and congressmen and
women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for some of them
because you'll never take back our
country with weakness you have to show
strength and you have to be strong
[Applause]
we have come to demand that Congress
do the right thing
and only count the electors who have
been lawfully slated lawfully slated
I know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the Capitol Building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard today we will see
whether Republicans stand strong for
integrity so here's one thing there's
the things that we laugh about
he's actually being very careful there
with that speech thing and maybe not
support maybe not support all of them
maybe that maybe could be but then he
says lawfully slated
peacefully and paid he made sure to say
follow the law yeah and he said
peacefully and patriotically now you may
disagree with them you may think he's a
quack because you think this is the
safest and most secure election in
history and many Americans do that's
fine the problem is the lie to say that
he encouraged any violence or even I'll
take it a step further unlawfulness
right or even that he wanted that to be
no
he's not trying to Stage a coup that
wasn't the whole point of this the whole
point for Donald Trump was I in his
opinion laws were broken
states did not legally certify their
slate of electors and so therefore it
needs to be sent back so it can be
corrected so the law can be followed
that was his entire argument the entire
time right right because he still had
the nuclear launch codes at that moment
if he wanted a coup he could have done
it I would never stay jakku Aku is for
doves or they go cuckoo if it's Steve
bannon's wife stage and oink
isn't that right move
[Laughter]
to
decertify Bray the whole hearing is just
insulting his wife just like Don Rickles
why don't you go to Alaska and step on a
rake huh she says huh
yeah hockey puck I don't even know what
that means
and by the way if these are writers and
insurrectionists and it's 911 the sequel
they accomplished nothing the election
was certified that exact same day to be
clear I do remember the speech they gave
before 9 11 that was like this to
peacefully fly the planes into the
buildings yes patriotically yes
patriotic yeah the the Q Anon Jihadi we
all remember him yeah they were like
should we let this guy with paint and
horns on the plane yeah yeah he's
totally fine no it's fine TSA just let
him bring the car batteries and wires
that's how you know that's actually a
good point that's how you know there was
no coup because when you're doing
something unlawful you typically try and
disguise yourself like a terrorist right
right and these in this case they were
letting their freak flag fly because
they weren't planning anything this is
the issue it's something that got out of
control something that got out of hand
for some people a very very small subset
of people to be clear okay here are some
uh other claims that we're making here's
another claim and now I believe on
number three for people who are
following along again the hashtag is lwc
Jan sixth anywhere you can get it
trending if you're on Instagram if
you're on Twitter if you're on Facebook
please do because we want people to
reference this is your reference guide
for all things January 6 related they
took it off they decided to leave we're
not another claim I'm going to make is
that Donald Trump even though okay let's
go with this he said make your voices
heard peacefully but he didn't condemn
the the insurrectionists he didn't
condemn The Hooligans uh strongly enough
or quickly enough this is something else
that they were going to trot back out
today because they did it last time my
question's exactly that
that sounds like you from the very onset
from violence the capital right around
two o'clock we're pushing for a strong
statement that people should lead to
Capital is that right
I was in other Soldier as well so your
advice was Louis Vuitton wallpaper over
two hours and there were subsequent
statements made tweets put forward then
in your view were insufficient did you
continue it was discipline throughout
the period of time up until 4 17
continue and others to push for a
stronger abstain yes
were you joined in that effort by Ivanka
Trump yes Eric Hershey yes on Mark
Meadow by the way right after that he
slept down a burlap sack and said all
these letters to Santa Claus yep and
they said if you were a woman I'd slug
you
the truth obviously Donald Trump did
tell them to go home here you go in case
you didn't see it first okay we're going
to go to that right now here's a message
from president Trump
I know you pain I know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen from
us it was a landslide election and
everyone knows it especially the other
side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace we have to have Law and Order
we have to respect our great
people in Law and Order we don't want
anybody hurt it's a very tough period of
time there's never been a time like this
where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us from me from
you from our country this was a
fraudulent election but we can't play
into the hands of these people
we have to have peace
so go home we love you you're very
special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are so bad and
so evil
I know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
so a couple of things there first
people love order he just said I love
Law and Order Play the theme
that's People's Court
for people of course
shut up
that sex crimes divisions
oh that's the Miami one We Won't Get
Fooled Again touch oh that's that's
that's right that's csmiami what's that
David care didn't want to be or be in
the Sun
a
Caruso's not the joke what's the
greatest in each one it's all who
soundtracks but here's the thing people
will say oh yeah but he was saying we
need to be peaceful but he was saying
this election was stolen a landslide
read read Hatter and when friends and
influence people look it would have been
worse if Donald Trump just came out and
said nothing happened please go home he
needed to say I hear you I understand
why you're upset you have reason to be
upset you need to acknowledge that
people are upset why they're upset and
then tell them that in spite of that
this is the course of action have you
ever had an argument with your spouse
you read a teenager who acts out if you
just say do it this way because I say so
how does that work out you always need
to say look I understand why you might
see it this way and I think you may have
some valid reasons but this is what we
have to do right now that is actually
what was necessary and he would be
damned if he did damned if he didn't if
he just came out and said be peaceful
they would say oh that wasn't enough if
he comes out and he relates to them and
says I understand why you're upset but
this is how we have to do it oh look he
was he was saying look did you hear he's
they got mad he said we love you
is he supposed to say we hate you to the
hundreds of thousands of protesters who
are there peacefully that's what he was
talking to when he said we love you we
hear you and most of the people by that
point I think had already kind of
started Meandering out right when you
have to home anyway you have to admit
that using the Dale Carnegie you know
analogy of the way that you know you use
the tools from that book yeah mixed with
narcissism is just beautiful yes it's
just I understand I hear you it was a
landslide we won I know but he's right I
mean that's what he's doing he's
endearing himself to make them know that
you know he understands them but he
doesn't want this to go in the direction
that it looks like it could go because
in no way is that what he wanted and you
know what though Donald Trump for all of
his faults he would do this with people
who opposed him as far as you the
citizens politically unlike Joe Biden
who's attacked the citizens as Mago
Republicans and walked it back oh gosh
again it's a lie where he prays white
supremacist neo-nazis I mean you know
maybe we can pull that clip actually
let's have guys in the control room pull
that clip because it's another myth I
just want to hit uh they keep
regurgitating it but think about what he
said he said I'm not I'm not talking
about neo-nazis white supremacists who
should be condemned totally but they
were very fine people on both sides
that's him saying hey I understand you
who want to take these statues down I
understand but you can't do it this way
he would do that with Democrat voters
just not with the politicians his
problem if you go through the entire
hearing the last hearing if you go
through the entire sequence of events
I would challenge you to find Donald
Trump condemning half the country as
evil you won't find it right no and look
you got to understand the mood of the
country at this time too it's like we're
taking this stuff in a bit of a vacuum
when they present it like all these
things happened and people just denied
the election no Donald Trump ran you
guys pulled him as one of the worst
candidates possible to run this was a
coronation kind of tribute to Hillary
Clinton and then Donald Trump wins and
we're like oh okay the media can't
really be trusted and then immediately
it was well Donald Trump didn't win on
his own Hillary didn't really believe
that he won it was Russia that actually
colluded with him to help steal the
election for years like Facebook ads
basically maybe several maybe tens of
thousands of dollars in Facebook ads
which is not a whole lot there's an
entire documentary on HBO called kill
chain that said Stacy Abrams won the
election because Dominion voting
machines can be hacked and rigged you
can watch on HBO right now they were
hacked live on that show right yes to
say that Stacy Abrams who by the way has
not conceded that election
HBO go and watch it well then a certain
group also came to the uh the to Zucker
at Facebook and told them to slide it
another way well yeah no the angle is
like down oh sorry that's what it is I
can't see your wonderful over and over
and over again to Donald Trump they were
trying to tear him down the media was
just complicit with everything and so
when this happens the election happens
we all see it we see it change in the
middle of the night we're thinking
democracy is being stolen right now
Donald Trump called it these guys are
doing it the media is carrying their
water and now we can't have a voice
because if you say it you're an election
denier right and these people are just
going there to protest this happening
Yeah we actually have a a question from
Blaze chat about the protesters and I've
got a few videos okay sure what's the
question yeah so Luis J asks is there
evidence that the security guards let in
the Gen six protesters you mean videos
oh video evidence yeah we've run that
many times on the show
videographic evidence from you know what
I will actually before we go to the
clips it's remember when DVD first came
out and they would say you could watch
things from 360 Degrees oh yeah with DVD
it's digital so you can actually we all
knew that that anyone who worked in film
there's no way that's possible unless
there's a camera there you can't
possibly but this is what they used to
say about DVDs for people who are
younger and watching we thought it was
going to be this new technology it was
like 3D at home and you could move
around to space like it was some kind of
you know architectural Who Sold you that
I mean that's what they said back then
but we actually do have that guide
Circuit City yes Comp USA yeah where the
receipt can cover the equator three
times a check yes true so serious City
receipts yeah you're like so the the
this box is for the TV and this one's
for the receipt what you need a receipt
this long to tell me that you don't have
a return policy yeah when do I come back
we're not going to be here in three
weeks
we're setting up phones right now yeah
so that's a good question and again a
lot of credit.com mug club we take these
questions every day for people who watch
the show every day we do another 100 of
show we do the show is times two every
day we take the questions uh you get 20
off if you use the promo code uh Jan six
you can use it now for the next 48 hours
I believe you have the footage there
token Allen yeah I got three videos it's
just gonna take me a minute to go
between the three Oh I thought you were
saying that you had it ready well let me
put it here's the first one yeah here
you go you wanted evidence and we'll
make sure this is up with the references
at ladderscredit.com
the criticism of police action ranges
from questioning their effectiveness to
questioning their effort one Tennessee
Congressman says at times officers
appeared complicit and that he's never
seen a crowd less afraid of police
all right no we have better clips than
that Shaman saying yeah
with our C game come on control room
otherwise I'm gonna go out we're going
to go to people at work I gotta be
honest I saw a few groups in the last
couple years that seemed less afraid of
police yeah
also less afraid of Walgreens yes they
were yeah I've got another one of a
police officer actually there's no more
respect for Walgreens yeah I I have
three streets in Seattle they seem
totally not terrified it's almost like
they didn't fear any ramifications to
their actions whatsoever yeah crazy
almost like they were you know like a
like a woman yeah let's grab uh
let's grab this grab them again if I
just agreed with that it's not even
thinking
we're going to be heard everybody this
must be peaceful this has to be
peacefully assemble and that guy has
been uh put in jail and held without
bail for well I believe three years and
nobody got or is that what he said he's
still in there actually the Q Anon
Shaman I don't know I know some people
he's in jail he still is he's been
convicted no he's been convicted three
years right I think he got three three
years three to five he was a pretty big
sentence yeah so think about that was he
trespassing sure you just heard him
after uh uh uh Capitol Police uh
detective there Seth Rogen said you can
come in him saying let's be peaceful
just think about do you think you heard
that from any hijackers on 9 11. you
think you heard that from any actual
insurrectionist group Enthusiast
throughout all of human history yeah
honest question though is it trespassing
if it's a public building you're allowed
to go into and the guys laying down
ground rules for you to be in he was
invited I think when he went if he went
into Pelosi's office it's hard for me to
keep track of who went into which office
right no no I know that in that moment
no in that moment that's not trespassing
okay that's what I was people's house
right it's got a name like you're
allowed to go in there are rules right
in times that's why it's been so
confusing to me yeah I realized they
went into Parts they weren't supposed to
and that's a different thing but well
there's other video where they go and
open the doors and like wave people in
and it's the most calm kind of well
there's videos where they pull down the
gates and they wave people in right
right and then there are videos remember
that one guy saying you have to stop
this you have to stop this when they
were actually trying to break down the
barricades and the Capitol Police are
waving the head no not doing anything so
we have videos of all these we'll make
them available on the references I don't
necessarily know which ones we have in
the uh in the tricaster right now okay
here's and by the way one final note
um encouraging behavior and not
condemning it strongly enough are very
very different things one if it's
actually encouraging violence of course
that can be a crime that is a crime if
you're found to be encouraging or
calling people to violence Donald Trump
condemned them they don't like the way
that he condemned any of the actual
violence and they said that he didn't do
it quickly enough even though he did it
keep him keep in mind what's pivotal
preemptively he said peacefully he's
said it beforehand
afterward so this brings us to the next
claim which is sorry I've got the clip
of the police officer waving them in oh
okay all right we'll show this uh
yeah
oh my God
he's literally waving them through right
there he looks like a black noise he was
squatting a fly oh that's right damn
Beast
yeah it's not like ABC Warehouse get a
dryer that's what they want you know
with no bushes no honey around no
flowers but base I mean I learned how
Tommy Boy that's how you get rid of cops
she saw Avalon that's what put young
Elijah Wood in the hospital
or if you're a my girl fan or yeah
that's how you put him in a casket
where is glasses he can't see without
his glasses yeah he can't see it oh he's
dead
where are the coins on his eyes for the
boat man and I don't mean the glass is
like that [ __ ] on CNN who wears fake
glasses do we still have that little
tricaster wear his glasses the most
useless glasses ever yesterday this is
how you know look oh look at that
where's glasses we don't know oh my gosh
he has them
he still can't see those are the glasses
you wear at Zales I fix tiny tiny pocket
watches
the teeniest ones you've ever seen it's
awesome
every gay kiss begins with him look at
my glasses uh he went to Jared uh
Kushner all right so we have the most
pernicious I would say one of the worst
claims because it seems really bad and
and I tell you what if this if this
happened to be true it would upset me
but it's not right that Donald Trump uh
wanted to have and granted he's a wiener
former vice president uh he shares the
same title as a former Vice President
Joe Biden former vice president Mike
Pence killed you've heard them make this
claim they were going to make this today
in a newly released interview former
president Trump defending rioters who
chanted hang Mike Pence during the
January 6th Capital Insurrection the
audio is from an interview with ABC
news's Jonathan Carl conducted at
Mar-A-Lago back in March Carl asked him
whether he was worried about vice
president Mike Pence's safety during the
riot Mr Trump then said it was quote
common sense for rioters to call for
pens to be hanged be worried about him
now look at the context here were you
worried about it I thought he was well
protected and I I had heard that he was
in good shape watch how he mutters no
because uh he mutters while Trump is
cheating but
he could have well the people were very
angry because it's it's Common Sense
John it's common sense
that you're supposed to protect how can
you if you know a vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to Congress so the context first off you
have to take into account that Donald
Trump is in a very loud crowded area you
can hear it he sounds like a mess hall
stuff in the back yeah he was saying
it's Common Sense wow Jonathan Carl was
saying they said hang up and he goes
like this they said hung my prince he
was already saying it's Common Sense
think about that through a telephone
when you're in a loud area he clearly
was not addressing Mike Pence that's why
you can't find anywhere else him
suggesting that people should hang Mike
Pence or him suggesting that people
should commit violence against Mike
Pence he didn't like Mike Pence
would that be your answer right to that
if somebody said you should hang my
pants
everyone wants to hang back Trump was
gay because a few minutes later he said
homo says what yes
what was that what
that's all the guy did it's it's it's
it's very childish so for them to
actually use that as if it's a piece of
evidence is just absurd and by the way
it also is a setup of they were saying
hang Mike Pence as though it's
legitimate have you guys now remember
there was the Washington Post or New
York Times I don't remember here they
had the picture of the noose right that
was ready for Mike Pence and you look at
it and it looked like they built those
had they had built some Gallows yeah we
have someone in there a little person
for scale here's that noose the picture
of the hanging Mike Pence can you zoom
in on that a little bit there look at
that look at that scroll it up barely
bigger than the blankets or the flag but
it's really rough when they kick the
bucket out and he's still kneeling yes
it also doesn't look like it's put
together very well and it's also bungee
cord it gives why don't you just build
it out of three candy canes and tinsels
it would have the same effect
in the garage
whatever the word is it's a little
person
a little person I didn't realize it was
a little for it's a very little person
it a person would uh well a person would
probably be looking up at Robert Reich
yeah don't you dare bring him up I won't
don't you dare I brought the Gallows who
did it's just this little guy yes I
don't know what height is is this right
I made it two feet bigger than me right
you read the quote it says hang Mike
Pence
hey then he demanded right answer him
these questions three it was weird
so no one was actually trying to hang
Mike Pence again you look at political
rhetoric too I think it's irresponsible
of course you shouldn't go there with
any kind of a nuisance but you know it's
the equivalent to a paper mache hat yeah
and Donald Trump was not addressing that
no I mean it's crowds get out of control
but when you heard the crowd chanting
have you ever been to a football game
and you hear certain chance kind of
start but fizzle nope and then other
football games you're like oh okay like
they're really big into this nobody was
really going along with it there was a
handful of people maybe 20 or 30 people
that were kind of chanting that it
wasn't in unison this strong voice from
the crowd like the entire 200 000 people
were chanting it do you mean like when
you were at Notre Dame and some people
started cheering your chanting your name
you just heard
foreign
let me kneel down I would have to hang
myself the worst executioner ever you're
like you have to request that you hang
yourself he doesn't have to give you a
wire and be like who do you do it yeah
department stores where they have to
pull down the blinds yeah you're gonna
regret your sins
[Laughter]
you talked about MSNBC and the the media
like misrepresenting it here's the photo
that they showed there you go yeah
it's almost like they cut it off right
where the Bemidji form is
which is almost kind of pivotal because
I guarantee you if you were giving
schematics to an executioner
he would demand you include the floor
yeah that's not gonna work why because
it's only four feet high yeah you've
ever seen one of these bills if we get
there to hang this guy it better not be
four feet off right round the only
person who could have hung himself
without ten
laughs
and he would have had to have Hillary
Clinton somewhere near this isn't going
to work at all
I mean think about it it's like where
are you gonna do this this is very
impractical but Santa's Workshop they
made it
he's an angry elephant
here at Grumpy's here with his noose
but pretty soon he'll be sleepy
long sleep
off to hang the VP we go
yeah it's like Trump was in a timing
news made a paper mache
this is rickety oh my gosh
I never knew that but no this is news I
only saw I only saw the one picture can
we get them side by side can you guys do
that just so that people I guarantee
people will want that for scale it's
just again none of this is real the
media and this is why I say when people
say oh a lot of you guys do sketches
well first off this is an entertainment
show yeah we provide more references
than they have the entire time we've
been broadcasting on CNN they don't do
it they want to operate in the darkness
all we really want is for you to start
educating yourself and doing your own
research you may disagree with the point
but we provide the research and by the
way if you go look at the references a
90 of them are Washington Post New York
time coming from salon.com we try and
use liberal sources consistently unless
it's one that is a lie and has to be
refuted by an accurate Source but this
that that was uh that was MSNBC right
that was their image and I guarantee you
that also went out on major Publications
was probably a bit covered Time cover I
mean that's that looks like a Time cover
image right that you'd be like oh yeah
well that's the image I've seen I I've
never seen the one of the little person
no of course you I've only seen the
other one not the Oompa Loompa
hey look at CNN is still on the same
show what do you get when you certify
fraud yeah
oh she's doing it with her other hand
now because she's not really sure what
the wind is blowing why aren't you
holding your hat right now because I'm
in North Carolina yeah I'm in a
I'm in Scranton Pennsylvania
it's just fake
I'm gonna get his food because we're
saying that it told her no I feel bad
for the people of course right it's the
fact that they want you to think that
this is the issue right when you see in
films the reporter who's doing this
who's doing the story and getting the
scoop defying the odds no matter how the
powers that be come against them it
doesn't exist they do the bidding of
those in power yeah if you had to guess
which of those pictures do you think
they showed at the hearing oh it's got
to be the big one well if I were a
betting man
be significantly more than I mean that's
the leading we already know the answer I
assume yeah what do we have an image of
them showing it at the hearing yeah or a
video all right
and you know there was an audible Gap
that one's even higher up yeah it is
yeah it's as big as the capital
that's the biggest news I've ever seen
what this does by the way I'm sorry they
slap on they're like like the Twix ads
and comic books saying actual size yeah
do you know what this does it feels the
next problem that's right all this does
you basically are just vilifying people
you've made it you made a comment on
earlier people being held without bail
or charges by the way until at least
August in some of the cases right do the
math January to August right that's a
long period of time I know they didn't
get them that day but pretty close after
that this fuels rage from people when
you lie and intentionally misrepresent
things
[Laughter]
it looks like she's standing outside of
Macy's you know they went to Home Depot
right before this here's the 10 foot
ones if you want the written now let's
let's get the fight can you show it
again it looks like she looks like when
I was like like she might be like a tiny
like [ __ ] kazakhstani in the Caucasus
Mountains oh like she's like she's a
sherpa those are five foot boards gotta
be five minutes it's just what was left
over from the Home Depot Halloween
section yeah yeah you guys don't need
these uh four by fours do you right no
you can take that oh no wait hold on I
need part of it you know that's not it's
now a four by three you're fine that's
enough yeah do you have any uh uh light
rope that couldn't hold a neck yes
uh no you might want to try Party City
perfect maybe some streets yeah maybe
you know like uh like bungee-ish yeah
there's still googly eyes on it from the
display at Michael's just you know
string
that's why you need Jim Jordan on this
couch be like Oh you mean this picture
it pops it up and it's just a theater
where they also they want as though by
the way as though they weren't also
saying that Mike Pence was a Nazi who
wanted to electrocute gays let's just be
clear if anyone wouldn't be trusted
alone with a woman and that's why he had
a policy where he wouldn't go out to
dinner with a woman alone I can't
believe it you can't control you I think
Mike Pence is a wiener for a lot of
reasons but that's one that's one where
I would support him the weirdest one
though is the fly landing on his hair
during the debate and walking around in
you know 20 minutes well it's you know
it's because he's the devil
and that's why if you knew anything you
can't kill the devil with rope it needs
to be silver they have that right it's
silver it's funny there's more and more
flies like Amityville yeah he's just
covered in like 80 of them where's John
coffee when you need it that takes you
out he's like chop that wood
he's not even moving you're like does he
not care I don't at all all right and
we'll take some more ear let me go
through another claim truth and let's
take a question before I we had a bunch
prepared so we just we're gonna do it
anyway so there's no January 6th hearing
but here you go you're welcome uh here's
another claim that they've made and they
were going to reiterate here today I
guarantee you well you have the truth
that's the claim
I'm [ __ ] thank you
that's the guy who built the Gallows
it doesn't make it through
uh they always claim of course you know
it's already wrong because I've
foreshadowed enough here that uh
president Trump never deployed the
National Guard
there's no indication
that President Trump ever made a call to
have the guard deployed
or had anything to do with the guard
being deployed When It ultimately was
okay he said never which by the way
tells you he's a stupid person because
they tell politicians advisors will tell
you don't use terms like never or always
bad idea uh because they want to give
them wiggle room to lie but in this case
he he fears accountability zero percent
I mean there is zero concern about
retribution to the point that he just
says uh he never ever deployed the
national so it makes our job a lot
easier because guess what Donald Trump
actually offered to deploy the National
Guard we have the image here in the days
multiple times leading up to January 6th
yeah who denied it Nancy Pelosi and
guess why she denied it
she didn't want to have a heavy police
presence that day I wonder why you knew
they had concerns about this they had
meetings about drugs in her purse yeah
exactly you knew that there were going
to be a lot of angry protesters there
right right that were going to be
protesting in the capital hundreds of
thousands of people were going to be
descending upon the capital you knew it
you had plenty of time to call up to
National Guard and have security I
wonder why you wouldn't want to do that
you know what actually to uh edit Bay
there bring up the footage that we have
of was it was only a few weeks before
this or maybe it was a couple months
before this when they were breaking down
the barricades trying to get to the
White House when they burned down the
church right across and everyone was
calling Donald Trump a coward right
because they said oh he's hiding in the
White House like what's he supposed to
do come out and meet rioters in the
summer right it was during the summer so
bring up that footage there was a more
violent protest by the way yeah they
burned down a church and then Donald
Trump the story was he held a Bible
upside down when he took a picture there
right and you just experienced that and
the mayor even comes out right she comes
out and says no I don't want these
people out here either because she's
buying into the lie that the police are
too brutal and she doesn't want to have
a repeat of what happened well no no I
would say it's even worse this is just a
theory okay and again right now we're
speculating so I just want to be clear
first off
this would be my guess if Donald Trump
said many times hey let's deploy the
National Guard here when there's this
this rally in Washington DC he's
probably not aiming to encourage his own
supporters to violence that would just
be my guess he wouldn't request the
National Guard now why would the mayor
of D.C and her name is uh uh yes Muriel
uh browser you mean Bowser sorry Bowser
you know she's the final
um Mario yeah
I thought it was I thought it was Koopa
it's Bowser Bowser
but ah one of the Kings yes Nancy Pelosi
the princess is in another Castle oh no
give me the flute I could skip a couple
of years that's right so
smart Mario 3D it's a sub-genre of humor
Nancy Pelosi and the mayor of DC said no
so Donald Trump said we need a National
Guard they said no
and this is immediately following or not
long after I should say I don't want to
be fact checked until I'm incorrect it
was the summer uh violent outbreaks
where they were attempting to actually
storm the White House and they did burn
down a church across from the White
House so maybe it's because Nancy Pelosi
in the mayor again speculating thought
if we bring them in they might stop the
violence that's been committed
throughout this uh these last two years
against Trump supporters they probably
if they don't want armed guards it would
suggest well not that they don't believe
there could possibly be violence there
can always be violence especially when
it's politically charged in an
environment with that many people
everyone knew there would be hundreds of
thousands of people okay everyone knew
that Nancy Pelosi mayor Bowser knew that
Donald Trump knew that okay everyone
knew there would be a divide because you
would have people there who had issues
with the election who were there to
support Donald Trump this is knowledge
that everyone had and everyone knew
there would be counter protesters
everyone knew that the summer before
that they attempted to storm the White
House and they burned down a church
everyone knew that there were billions
of dollars in damage images riots across
the country in the Years following this
right everyone knew that everyone knew
there were thousands of Officer
casualties they all knew that and Donald
Trump said let's be prudent let's have
some armed guards they said no I would
say for the same reason that they gave
black lives matter and anarchists an
entire 2-3 city blocks in Seattle
they were hoping that there would be
some kind of violence yeah then they
could point to it just like they are
right now and say see we're here to save
you from this no I mean
and this is the summer
yep well so this isn't January 6th this
is not January 6th that's the church
right yeah yeah I remember that wasn't
burning down the church and then there
should also be them hitting trying to
kick down the barricades right there in
front of the white house so the idea
that this was the most violent protest
hey both had the same amount of
casualties
nothing was burned aside from the
protester herself Ashley Babbitt right
there uh she's the only one who was shot
uh but there was certainly more property
damage
how many people how many people were
held without bail from that summer who
burned down the church by the way I'm
sure we can find a picture of the church
burnt down how many people
that's a genuine question I don't know
was anyone held for months without bail
and I don't mean was anyone charged and
then convicted in a speedy manner which
is a fundamental right of Americans yeah
yeah uh how many people were held
without any kind of conviction without
bail for months or without charges
if any if any anyone who burned down
that church
just a question I honestly don't know I
don't think any but
uh all right so here's another so isn't
it sorry but isn't it
isn't it illegal in America or at least
at some point to hold someone without
bail for a certain amount of time yes
no
because they can because they chose to
do it yes the Law changes I guess at the
whim of the former vice president and
right and by the way these are the same
people who this isn't new they wanted to
impeach and they wanted to put George W
bush on trial as a war criminal because
of Guantanamo Bay because they said you
can't hold people without trial when we
were talking about non-american citizens
who were terrorists involved in plots to
murder American citizens they said that
was cruel you couldn't do that but
they've done it to actual American
citizens why well now they label them
terrorists and apparently they're Pro no
trial Pro no due process
for Citizens if they claim that they're
a terrorist and by the way I know what
what you're maybe thinking sure the
people in Guantanamo Bay these were
people who were actively trying to you
know bomb major cities but they weren't
invited into the capital and then uh
took a selfie in Nancy Pelosi's office
well cruel and unusual is definitely I
don't know what that is but Guantanamo
Bay too I mean there's families there
there's a Subway like it's not yes yes
it's not like a living hell you know
it's something oh I've been I've been
many times at Guantanamo Bay yeah it's
not you know you kind of just sit all
cruel and unusual and again yeah you're
right like they are being held without
trial but yes they're terrorists well
and again it's just about the
consistency from the left there's
certainly there is an absolute legal
argument that people who are not
American citizens whose only goal when
they are foreign threats is to kill
American citizens that they are not
entitled to American constitutional
rights
to scale that back people who live here
but are non-citizens but aren't visas
they don't get the same benefits as far
as Social Security here right there
there are levels there are tears to this
because citizenship is very different
now you scale that to okay what do we do
with terrorists who've never set foot in
the United States and only plan to come
here to kill people the left said they
absolutely are entitled to
constitutional rights representation a
trial they right it has to be a speedy
trial you can't hold them indefinitely
yeah but they do it for American
citizens
it's not that they're Hypocrites it's
that they don't believe what they're
telling you a hypocrite can be someone
who actually believes something a
hypocrite can be someone who says hey
kids don't do drugs and they have a drug
problem it doesn't make them a bad
person that makes them a weak person
these people don't believe what they're
feeding you they don't believe for a
second that these are terrorists or this
was the most violent or even close to
one of the most violent days in American
history they know it and if they don't
they can watch the stream problem solved
yeah the church was in June of 2020 and
then I got the barricade
um and some other valence okay of 2020.
here we go
because we've been gasped with so many
people have allowed this to be memory
hold
they're holding up Shields and you see
cherry bombs being thrown
happened January 6th yeah and that that
isn't even the worst no it's not even
though it's just been arrested I mean
there wouldn't be this trial even
happening no of course it happened and
the mayor basically was saying you know
they had unarmed Guardsmen that were
brought in as well so that's that's
helpful they were there to direct
traffic was like ah good yes take away
all of their ability to you know do
their jobs right uh fantastic but they
brought in Paul Blart see how many
people were there you see how many do
you see how many police officers were
there
with shields riot gear go to the videos
on January 6th did you see how many were
there they were protecting a much larger
area and there was a giant crowd of
protesters right at this point and by
the way these crazy cops were deployed
quickly because violence was already
being committed so in other words it can
be done Donald Trump said hey we had to
do this last time let's not be caught
flat-footed for and that tells you again
Donald Trump is saying that should apply
to both sides right you could you could
check the references he didn't say hey
only Guardsmen who by the way will only
take out liberal protesters he said
let's have the National Guard let's have
them there to ensure that it is peaceful
in other words you may not like them and
you may not like how he responded
afterwards I understand that but you it
doesn't pass a sniff test of course he
was intending for this to be peaceful or
he wouldn't have asked for armed guards
when you're right the traffic on that
stairwell and Lobby oh terrible it
really is it's hard to get to Pelosi's
office quickly wow it's like it's like
you're going through The Descent there's
catacombs hey let's grab a question here
because we have a bunch of other claims
but uh crumbs Let's uh do we have a
question here from a mug club person
before we get into Ray Epps that's a fun
one geez yeah oh gosh well actually
John cappuccino wants to know why are
they covering for Ray up so bad who is
he
bookmark this and I'll go back to Mike's
brother yeah so for people who don't
know yes
just a horrible prior by the way oh I
know it's terrible compared to like Jim
Brewer and there's a guy in Michigan I
swear to God he does a spot on prior
it's like just hire him oh is that the
guy who just like does stand up as
Richard yeah Martini Harris like it's
just do just hire him it is like you
probably shouldn't be making money don't
get me wrong there's there's certainly
not a reason you should be doing it but
if you're gonna make the biopic biopic
do they introduce him as Richard Pryor
do they introduce him as no no Martini
he does this act most of as himself oh
he will do like a chunk of it as prior
his name is what Martini Martini yeah
and you know when I had a heart attack
man I had a heart attack I was telling
my heart I couldn't breathe he's like
doing what you're praying I thought his
name was Martini yeah fortunately so
many gen z's are like I like this I've
never heard of it before
I don't watch anything made before in
1995. uh okay so Ray actually that's a
good uh that's a good question uh we'll
go to that we'll go back to some more
claims truth and again the hashtag is uh
hashtag lwcjn6 and uh we of course uh
are offering a promo code Jan sixth
letter with credit.com
that's the only thing that keeps us
afloat here uh we appreciate you
supporting us and allows us to do this
so Ray Epps for those of you who don't
remember
he was a guy and again there is some
level of speculation here yes there has
to be because these questions have gone
completely unanswered and I would say
there's enough cause
four questions and I would certainly say
that there's enough for uh people to be
required to provide answers at this
point especially when there's already a
committee right I mean this this seems
like the kind of thing that they what
are you doing committee oh no I'm in
committee really it's a [ __ ]
committee I thought I was going to
become a bill instead I've been used to
be put on the list chain is fat ass well
they tracked out all these people but
this guy's still but not him he's at
large yeah he's he's born apps on the
left yes
I said Richard Kimble
I don't care
I'm not a fed
all right freezeps Wicked it was the one
no man can survive that jump
[Laughter]
I want you to search every White House
Congress house senate house
church church house dog house everything
all right so uh
has a really funny bit about how he he
thought Tommy Lee uh sorry Tommy Lee
Jones was gay you ever hear that oh he's
like oh my dad told me he's like my dad
told me I was watching him uh and he
said oh yeah I used to I used to go to
college with him he's gay
and that was enough proof that I thought
I needed so I told people for 15 years
of my life
was gay I took my one guy said what I
was his roommate in college he's not gay
or something like this
he's so straight foreign
all right okay so and please hit the
like button hit the share again it's
what helps with the algorithm I hate to
be that guy who who requests that of you
don't hit like there you go okay you do
it
[Laughter]
here are a few videos for those to
refresh your memory and I'll get into
the ins and outs of uh of Ray Epps I
think we have a I think we have a
montage right Ray Epps from January 5th
and 6th in real time people thinking
that this man was an undercover agent
and then we'll give you some evidence
afterwards along with some speculation
as to why I
100 believe he is let's start
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
I'm probably gonna go to jail
tomorrow we need to go into the capitol
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the capital is this direction
foreign
to someone
[Applause]
okay now
to be clear maybe he's not a fed maybe
he's just maybe he just actually is one
of the very select few people who was
planning some kind of an insurrection
that would be a totally valid theory if
you watch those initial Clips you would
say Okay seems like it's one or the
other either this guy is somebody who
was causing trouble or he's someone who
is trying to uh unfortunately uh guilt
by association everybody else memory
hold people you know Gaslight people and
have you believe that everyone else was
being violent when it was really someone
like him it's one of those two
conclusions either he's a fed or he's
actually an [ __ ] now let me present
to you why I think that he was an
undercover agent because we've seen
what's happened they've made examples to
more moderate [ __ ] like the Q Anon
Shaman yeah right okay so revolver news
just to give you again some context we
have to go back in time to refresh your
memory they published a few pieces on
this guy right apps I think we can bring
it up uh uh right now yeah there you go
keep in mind he hasn't been indicted on
anything right
so compared to what we've seen and
compared to what with the consequences
we've seen he has not been indicted on
anything as a matter of fact the FBI uh
has raised picture under the seeking
information
well that's not very hard yeah his idea
right
you have video what else what other
information now in that picture can we
bring up that picture again he's the
last person seen speaking with a guy
named Ryan samsel okay right there
that's one of the first men to breach
the fence
now Epps is right there so sansil okay
Ryan was arrested in January and held
without bond or formal charges until
August 25th huh it's almost like that's
not speedy right charging then you have
he was after that Epps was taken off the
FBI Capital Riot most wanted list um
he's right there the guy he's with was
held until August just to be clear
rayaps is right there they know they
know where he is I know some of you
might be saying okay so now it seems
that there's some foul play but there
are several conclusions here either
there's foul or maybe they just can't
find them well it's interesting that you
might bring up that point uh when he was
asked by journalists who didn't have to
do all that much leg work they had a
phone book about January 6th raps
ran off he was easy to find
I've been trying to get a hold of you
we met January 5th we're Patriots
you remember me from January 6th I
understand that but I can't say anything
are you still under investigation by the
FBI
are you a federal informant is there a
reason why the FBI took you off the most
wanted list are you a federal informant
right Epps
it's not even gated
he has a six-person golf cart play-ups
alleged Federal informant
driving into his property
[Laughter]
yes
a one person if you're lucky so it's
Steve and his wife Golf Course
unbelievable so let's think about that
for a second it's not you don't live in
a free country because you have laws
you've heard me talk about this many
times it's you live in an actually free
country the laws are applied equally so
let's say he's not a fed
let's say he's not and I can't say
definitively that he is we're all
speculating here because we've not been
given any information despite the fact
that there's the most robust Committee
of all time that has been created robust
I said robust no that's what I'm saying
I'm just highlighting Oh I thought you
were correct robust I was like did I
just say Bust I got bust on the brain
admonish him it's a busty committee so
another guy is held without bail other
people from the riots are held without
bail
this guy is right there he's easily
found nothing
and no answers have been provided and he
was taken off the most wanted list so
now I would say I would argue this there
are only two uh possible conclusions
after the information that we presented
either he was a Fed who was there as a
plant beforehand or afterwards he worked
with them which maybe granted him some
kind of immunity
true doesn't seem very likely though the
latter considering that I don't believe
many people at all aside from I think
there was one person now with the proud
boys I think uh not many people have
been granted immunity at all if they
happen to work with conservative groups
they want scalps that's what they want
right that's all they have are scallops
they don't have evidence of real violent
crimes so they're looking for scalps so
if this guy afterwards said you know
what I'll I'll work with you for
immunity based on the history of the
democratic party I I can't imagine they
would take it yeah somebody didn't
control them I believe that uh one it
may it's either Jim Jordan or somebody
else was questioning somebody on a
committee about Ray apps and they kept
shutting him down is it massive yes he
was uh yeah see if we can find somebody
of that because there's a question about
who who's this Ray UPS yeah like that
that's insane it's hard to pull out any
information on Tim said he has it you
have it yeah it's a rep Massey uh
questioning Mary Carlin oh yeah this is
one of the most certain investigations
in the history uh have you seen that
video
so as I said at the outset one of the
Norms of the justice department is to
not comment on an impending
investigations and particularly not to
comment about particular scenes or
particular individuals I was hoping
today to give you an opportunity to put
to rest the concerns that people have
that there were federal agents or assets
of the federal government present on
January 5th and January 6th can you tell
us without talking about particular
incidents or particular videos how many
agents or assets of the federal
government were present on January 6
whether they agitated to go into the
capital and if any of them did and so
I'm not going to violate this Norm of uh
of the rule of law I'm not going to
comment on an investigation that's
ongoing yeah it's by the way it's such a
private investigation that it was
ongoing in prime time and they were
going to do it again today but they
wanted to make sure there was so many
people who were watching that they
decided to bump it because of the
hurricane you're about to say something
sir before well also that was wasn't
that the investigation kind of I mean
sort of yeah um how many people that
were arrested I would like to know or
have are giant landowners
have Farms like the this uh Mike Epps
brother
it seems like he's very well off it
seems yes seems pretty well if that was
his property yeah how many people went
down to the Capitol that had that kind
of money property or potentially that
were risking to lose that to go there
and convince people that they should
storm a capital right doesn't that seem
suspicious it does seem suspicious just
a little bit I don't know Neverland
Ranch yeah that's kind of my without the
monkey he doesn't have sparkles no but
he's I bet you as a system of bells yes
he does
anyway I was still half on that but yeah
and by the way it's not an odd thing you
know it's a completely legitimate and
especially because you know you're from
Michigan and obviously I was originally
from Michigan and we know where we had
the plot to kidnap Governor Whitmer
right a huge portion what was it was it
12 of the people 12 of them were FBI
informants yes
it was somewhere around 50 percent it
was of the people who were actually
planning on kidnapping Gretchen Whitmer
were actually federal agents I forget
the name of the uh the biggest terrorist
thwarting that had ever taken place
after 9 11. we should have this actually
somewhere I believe in the research dot
guys in the drive yeah the FBI or CIA it
was the majority of the terrorists in
that cell or faction they were actually
FBI agents not some of them the majority
of them and that was sold as you know
reason to continue the Patriot Act it
was look at this huge Terror plot that
we stopped I can't remember the name of
it I'm sure you guys can find it yeah
we've referenced it recently I'd like to
see it yeah I can't it was something I'm
going I think it was like 15 of the 19
people I want to say it was over half
and I believe some of them are in jail
somebody's at your desk is it the it's
Shaman isn't it well if he says no
respect he's got his feet up on it yeah
I'm gonna tell people that he pooped on
it later well then we can hold them for
three years that's what well that's what
you do you kind of make up what he did
all right you know what Sean I have
someone else go I need to refill on my
water anyway I think do you guys need
anything I need an energy drink I'm
gonna you know what yeah you know I need
to pee yeah well actually you know I'm
kind of hungry I'll have a beer oh are
you hungry
I'm hungry too oh you know what actually
uh do we have any of the bill bill bars
yeah I think we do I don't know can we
do that do you have any of the build
bars today do you know if they restarted
no I don't know do you guys know how
they restock
foreign
[Music]
come on guys we need these to film a
commercial you keep eating them
noise
don't make any sudden moves
[Music]
okay don't scream he's not gonna hurt
you it's just you gotta let him finish
friendly
I'm gonna miss him
foreign
[Music]
by the way I've told you guys it's there
it's the only sponsor that we have here
today on this show uh you can go to
built.com enter in the promo code I
think it's crowder15 again I got a tiny
monitor here for 15 off my I like to
double chocolate I like anything that
has a coconut in there and what's funny
is I don't really like coconut but uh oh
so you don't need protein bar you don't
need protein supplements no one needs
them but if you're trying to get some
more protein in and something that
actually tastes good they use real dark
chocolate I use it as like a dessert I
often eat them as if I put it in the
freezer yeah after surgery I started
gaining some weight you know about like
35 pounds in two weeks some of it was
blood uh
I actually that's what that honestly
happened I gained all this weight after
the surgery remember I was up at like
260. have I I completely cut out
desserts I can put out sugar then I cut
out carbs and then I got to the point
where I was eating one meal a day and it
was just like one steak or one pork chop
and like maybe some broccoli that was it
and I was still gaining weight yeah well
it turns out you know I collapsed a lot
I had five you're five and a half liters
yeah but when I replace the desserts at
first my in that stage and like let me
replace desserts with built bars and I'm
like this isn't working this usually
works like a charm because at night I
eat a bunch of crap I eat healthy during
the day and then eat crap at night and
it didn't and if that didn't work I knew
there was something going on I said
something's going on here and uh it
turns out that I was bleeding internally
so if that's not your situation you can
replace your desserts with filt bars
it's real Belgian dark chocolate
built.com Crowder 15 is a promo code it
wasn't the binge eating yeah you two can
lose weight just bleed internally bleed
internally and drink and don't forget
drink Mexican tap water that always
helps yes uh all right uh uh Dave is
gone we have so many more things to get
through I don't know if we want to take
some more of your questions are people
are are people feeling like this is good
for them a reference a piece for them
because I know like I know it's weird
there's nothing are they talking about
this on MSNBC at all guys out there does
anyone let us know where the channel
figure well I mean they can let us know
if they're just doing the hurricane yeah
I don't think I think everybody's on the
hurricane okay so let's go to the next
claim here another claim that they'll be
making again lwc Jan six is the hashtag
is that there are bunch of capital
police officers and we when we first
heard this by the way live on air we had
to go with the information that we heard
that at first it was three then it was
seven then it was five right Capitol
police officers died okay here's the
truth
none of them died
no Capital police officers died as a
result of what happened on January 6th
there was one person who died Ashley
Babbitt you've all seen that footage I'm
not going to show it now where she was
shot by the Capitol Police uh let me run
through the the names here of these are
the people they want you to believe died
okay uh Roseanne Boyland was one of the
people there I believe an officer that
was an amphetamine overdose
Uh Kevin greason died of a heart attack
Benjamin Phillips Trump supporter by the
way died of a stroke
officer sicknick remember this that was
the one they said was hit in the head
with a fire extinguisher he died January
7th of natural causes now I'm not going
to say that none of these are suspect
right I would like to see some
investigations into how did five people
die of natural causes so quickly
considering you are you're the guys with
the committee you're the guys running
the investigation
again if you're going to suspect Foul
Play Here considering that a lot of
these officers were supporters of Donald
Trump I would like to know how how these
many people died but it's certainly not
the story that we've been told uh
there's officer Jeffrey Smith suicide
January 15th officer Howard liebengood
suicide
and by the way just just to reiterate
the point uh that the media says five
people died just like I've been saying
this hearing is not an actual uh it's
not something that's actually taking
place in court this isn't a trial well
when you try and pass the legal
threshold the legal hurdles it doesn't
it doesn't pass muster how do you know
well okay we were just talking about
officer leaving good his widow has been
denied line of duty which would be like
benefits pensions things like that right
for uh a wife a widow of an officer in
the line of duty yeah didn't clear that
the media said he died there as a
capital police uh there as a capital
policeman they ran with that for months
behind the scenes is well we know this
isn't true before we all found out they
denied the claim for him dying in the
line of duty yeah one of so a couple of
things here one of them from our
researchers so the Boyland person was a
right attending not an officer she was
the one they claimed was crushed by the
crowd but actually turned out that she
was beaten by an officer while
unconscious
jeez that wasn't like a funny laugh that
was like geez I think you should report
on that line did you get a full energy
drink I did I didn't get any I just got
water that's good I want a little of
both I might need to take this one this
is energy no no that's okay real quick
real quick
so here's here's
here about this is that we knew very
quickly that these people didn't
actually die there that the officer was
not beaten to death with a fire
extinguisher which is basically what the
media had run with right afterwards
right we knew that very and by the way
we condemned it when we thought that was
the truth on air we said if this that's
horrible if anyone actually beat
somebody to death with a fire
extinguisher that was the information we
had at that time yeah but it comes back
out oh actually this person didn't die
then they died a couple of days later we
now have information that none of these
people actually died there none of these
people were killed by rioters they say
rioters and yet the media and key public
officials still quote I think Joe Biden
did it a month ago right saying that
people died on January 6 at the cap it
didn't happen right no by the way this
is the same uh same uh Administration
when I talked about the Barack Obama
administration that claimed women made
77 cents in the dollars like you don't
have access to you even if you can't
afford a smartphone as Google what about
bing one of the funniest things about
that was during that press briefing that
the liberal media that normally carries
the water was like we can't sell this
right that's not the right number here's
the number from your own blah blah blah
Department he goes we're sticking with
the 77 cents on the dollar I was like
dude
and did the one guy kill himself hanging
himself from what those Gallows oh okay
yes it was it was from the Tim Conway
dwarf yeah exactly actually it was the
uh Willow understudy ah good I just
hunted myself in a physically impossible
way yeah like Jeffrey Epstein yeah yes
like hung himself then held himself up
till his neck broke and did it with such
force that it shattered a bone they can
only be shattered yeah if you drop
somebody from a height no no he hung
himself from a coat rack in a motel six
oh man okay
yeah I do that from the I did that from
the luggage carrier one with their paper
mache walls that they
some shirt that's going to hold you up
yeah there's nothing sadder than trying
to kill yourself in a Motel 6 because of
one you're in a motel six and two it's
not gonna work
there's no way out it could be it could
be a super eight that's true yeah who
lives the light on for you yes
oh God I wish you would have turned it
off
stelter doesn't like it bright yeah
hotel six we'll leave the black light
off permanently yes please don't bring
one in right you know what I do have to
go I have to use the restroom here
because I'm not a robot and uh we're
going to come back and not only take
more of your questions again it's
hashtag lwc Jan six but the uh the promo
code for Mud Club is Jan 6th and you get
20 off please if you like watching the
show and we always do an additional hour
every day consider supporting it's the
only thing that allows us to do this
we're going to come back and get to
their star witness at the last hearing
who they were going to uh recycle was
going to be you know this hearing was
basically going to be a retreat of the
last hearing remember Cassidy Hutchinson
Cassidy Hutchinson we're going to give
you the ins and outs of Cassidy
Hutchinson uh when we come back because
this is kind of pivotal to what they
want to present going forward this will
be a couple of minutes I'll be right
back after I relieve myself
[Music]
together
[Music]
okay sir you're gonna be all right we
have help on the way where are you uh
you know okay what is anything broken my
leg is stuck but it's not really like no
no that's not gonna work I said no
Journey
don't worry about it we're going to be
here we're staying right here with you
okay so just listen to the sound of my
voice
Earth Wind and Fire perfect that'll work
that'll work
I think I kind of sprained it pretty bad
not gonna lie but I mean I can move it
so it's like
wait what was that
what's up
guys
[Music]
louder with Crowder now officially
sponsors monster trucks monster trucks
monster truck look at that monster truck
and we didn't actually sponsor a monster
truck they just put our sticker on it
because we don't have any money money
turns out monster trucks are expensive a
lot of money watch this monster truck go
fast and crush the competition
guys tone it down with better.com
to help us get stickers on monster
trucks
this is Franklin he looks so happy
doesn't he that's because he's about to
be turned into a pair of Barbie sparker
glasses
it's quite a process but we're here to
guide you through it first Franklin will
be removed from his shell then his shell
will be crushed into hundreds of tiny
pieces these pieces will then be melted
together into a sheet and cut by a large
machine into your designer frame of
choice after a final quality check
Franklin is ready to be sent out to you
the customer wondering what happens to
the rest of Franklin well here at Barbie
sparker we believe in giving back that's
why for every pair of Barbie sparker
glasses ordered we send one can of
turtle soup to a Chinese homeless
shelter of your choice thanks Barbie
sparker
and thank you Franklin
[Music]
good Lord
who's rapping now
[Music]
in your code
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys sorry my mic was muted
there I said some very profound things
when you just saw my lips moving and
heard nothing we're coming back so we've
got one more person we're going to talk
about we're going to take some chats so
make sure you're sending in those
questions we want to make sure we get to
those and then we're gonna go to mug
Club here in just a little bit Steven's
right off camera he's peeing in the
studio again which is weird
um I told him not to do that but make
sure you send those chats in where they
get to some of those and like I said go
to Monkey by the way uh star witness did
you guys all like how testy Gerald just
got this mic wasn't on he was going oh
yeah hey hey
you're crashing my bike do you guys
think I'm you guys think I'm tough
Gerald is just an absolute Tyrant I'm
very nice right up until I'm Relentless
twice since you're lucky only twice
all right let's get some chats
get some chats all right
chats can't do the voice I wish I could
do the Christopher Walken for chats
chats
oh no I mean oh it's chats listen
Cassidy Hutchinson she's not bad looking
this she's a lying [ __ ] yeah you might
want a woman who behind you talk I mean
he's like oh [ __ ]
that was a third all right yes we got it
you can leave now thanks you'll be in
jail soon
why would they give me well that works
better than an energy drink
did you know he was there
I
am jumpier than Finnegan I did the same
thing I'm already anxious I look around
like [ __ ]
your holster it looked like the chick
from smile
[Laughter]
yeah if he was a shot you have to be
like that was the real Shaman
nobody nobody cares yeah that was Ashley
Babbitt's brother I guess we're good
totally acceptable is this for Gerald or
is it for uh who's that for all right
that's okay go ahead bring it on you
don't need to worry well that people
won't see you you've already destroyed
future employment opportunities anyway
yeah all right
it's all over yeah and uh again the
promo code is Jan sixth sorry I'm gonna
burp oh don't do it down dead I just had
to check something fizzy because I could
you can't drink coffee that quickly
um
look let's take some shots
all right
makeshift wants to know was Ashley
definitively trying to get through the
door heard there was a witness saying
she wasn't no she was climbing through
the window yeah she was climbing through
the window which I'm not entirely sure
was open until the bullet went through
it no no so it was it was definitely
open so there's video evidence of this
Ashley Babbitt has seen stopping
somebody from actually going through the
window and I think she decks the guy uh
which was kind of funny at the in the
moment and then she at that moment in
time he didn't know what's happening
eight seconds later right yes exactly
wasn't she coming in though and down
when she gets shot so there's a hallway
that is separated right so you've got
stairs yeah you've got a little kind of
I don't know maybe 15 or 20 feet and
then doors and window that lead to a
hallway so it's kind of basically like
another checkpoint for Safety and
Security for I guess a chamber where you
have access to the politicians who are
in the building right so I understand
that there is a police officer if you're
looking at that door and you've got the
protesters who's crouched down on the
left hand side on the opposite side of
that right so there's glass there's wood
and then there's a door in the middle
the window that was broken is on the far
right
you see Ashley Babbitt there the entire
time and then she climbs through she
puts you try to get up yeah she tries to
climb through the window and when she
does the police officer shoots what the
police officer could easily have done is
anything else
back through the window
literally seconds later
reinforcements show up coming up the
stairs and disperse the crowd so this
crowd wasn't like this gigantic threat
now I understand maybe there are red
lines you could not cross this point
other otherwise we have to shoot first
but there was no investigation into this
person there was no releasing of the
name of this person immediately there
was no like here's what happened well
considering that with the Mike Brown
situation hands up don't shoot he was
reaching for a police officer's gun and
repeatedly punching him in the face this
was an unarmed protester now I get
people's like oh she was climbing
through a window play stupid games Win
stupid prizes I'm like no this this is
not this is not what we heard from you
guys right you guys said every police
officer who ever did anything to protect
their lives you dox them LeBron James
would tweet about this is the new face
of white supremacy even though this
person was saving somebody else's life
right right so that stuff happened but
not here right this one case right no
you're exactly and really the the
standard should be is the police
officer's life in jeopardy or someone
else's personal safety in Jeopardy and
in this case it wasn't no no it did not
it was not a readily is your life in
jeopardy is your personal safety in
Jeopardy and do you have other means of
eliminating the threat right those are
and we also understand there's a gray
area because sometimes you have to act
quickly but in this case you have a
pretty long fuse if you have someone
trying to get in through a window you
have one place to secure and she really
could just be pushed out
better yes I know that there's a video
of it yeah exactly you could have done a
lot of things but here's the thing all
you had to do to take care of this
situation okay let's say it's Justified
show us just just show us just talk to
this person try and understand why it
was justified and make the case because
that's what the police have to do when
somebody shoots a suspect they release
the body cam video they release every
other possible camera angle that they
can find there's lawyers that are
brought in if they even run this footage
I don't know this for a fact I don't
believe they ran the Ashley Babbitt
footage about the January 6th hearing
did they no of course not well I'm just
saying consider that I'm talking about
the violence that was the most violent
act that was committed the only person
killed that day on site yeah so yeah I
don't know maybe they should probably I
don't know it's a committee again seems
like this would be your job yeah but
every time the name Ashley Babbitt gets
brought up it's basically shouted down
yeah shut it down it's like oh this is a
stupid person and then they try and say
oh what what about the conservatives you
you don't and this is something
hopefully this prepares you for when
people make this argument when you say
defund the FBI
when you oh and by the way when I was in
uh we were in Arizona remember there are
the attack ads against Kerry Lake yeah
out of the hotel yeah I was like hey
I don't know if I texted you I can't
remember I was like can you believe this
[ __ ] it was it was Carrie Lake serious
and then it shows me saying I will not
support any uh Republican candidate who
does not believe in disbanding the FBI
and her saying well absolutely right
there needs to be something that is
constitutionally constrained or
seriously dangerous paid for by people
like oh my gosh I can't believe they
were going to use that against her but
even then who are you who do you think
you're turning off yeah who is it for I
know they're like all right I got a
perfect ad right we're gonna perfect
that her saying something that we all
would have supported last summer but are
now against and here's the thing it's
not at all inconsistent to say we
support uh appropriate local law
enforcement without a federal
militarization of police against its own
citizens of course you can support an
officer protecting his life or an
officer serving his community or an
officer a David Dorn type right of
course you can while also saying hey I
think the FBI in 80 000 80 plus thousand
new IRS sorry employees will get fact
checked if we say agents because
technically they're not all agents but
no one denies that there are 87 000 new
IRS employees many of whom will have
guns there's nothing inconsistent about
saying hey we think that there should be
appropriate local law enforcement and of
course we're against this uh no longer
constitutionally constrained FBI CIA and
now the IRS the National Intelligence
industrial complex it is just as
consistent as you saying there should be
no federal department of education and I
would personally rather live in a state
that has good Public Schools yeah and
they're accountable to No One this just
goes against their narrative like this
was right on the heels of them saying
that a police officer shooting a woman
about to stab another woman was wrong
because it was a black woman that was
shot and it was a white police officer
this comes on the heels of two cops
being physically assaulted and
overpowered by a guy being a black woman
who grabs exactly another black he was
saving a black woman grabs their uh
taser and is running off and trying to
shoot the officer with a taser and
shooting him all of these people were
saying you can't even do it then this
person this this person had nothing but
a backpack and a helmet on climbing
through and I'm just like where's the
consistency at least let's talk about
this and instead they're treating this
person like a hero like he saved the day
right maybe you did and if you did make
the case let's see the footage and let's
understand the policies that were in
place that said you had to shoot right
then he went to police School the same
place that man went to executioner
school with the Mike Pence news
we got a strike too for talking about
that that one incident the police
officer yeah save the the black girl
who's attacking oh that's we got a
stranger yeah yeah they said we were
Rebels yeah that's right oh that's right
the girl yeah we forgot her name and you
saved the person who said thank God you
saved the young black girl who called
the police who was in the process of
being stabbed and they said I think
because we probably also said that that
I can't repeat it other stuff we said
other things that you can go and watch
again on mud club.com anything that's
been banned on YouTube you can go to
Washington we have it all up there
well Rumble doesn't have all of it
though no no because back in
so anything in our catalog and to be
clear hundreds of millions of plays
wiped off of YouTube because we had to
delete some of these videos yeah I think
there's even a band archive on Mud Club
where you can go and specifically watch
the ones that you can't see on YouTube
so it makes them easy to find it all
right let's grab a couple more and then
we'll go you know what let's do the
Cassidy Hutchinson uh thing uh yeah mug
Club because it could spicy well it
could yeah it's one of those issues
where it could be truthful and that's
not allowed on YouTube let's grab some
chefs okay Keith Gola was pretty special
about the band oh wait one second sorry
I forgot I'm going to be at uh Bricktown
comedy club in Oklahoma City uh October
8th yeah October 8th I think and there's
only like 300 seats it's just working
out some new materials so uh and a good
guy who who runs that club uh and you're
gonna be in Bay City this weekend uh
this Saturday I'll be in Bay City come
on out me and Derek Richards Michigan
come out join us there you go all right
let's take another chat all right so
Keith wants to know when did you find
that Bannon was lying about being an
Insider in Trump Circle I wasn't aware
of his unwelcome status yeah because
he could be aware and look I know some
people will be mad
that we're talking about Donald Trump
taking a steaming dump on Steve Bannon
but he did
you may like Steve Van you could hey
it's also okay if you like Steve Bannon
and you disagree with Donald Trump
that's okay or maybe you like Donald
Trump and you also like Steve all of
these things are okay I'm just telling
you that this idea of of making Trump
Guilty By Association which is the media
that's what they want to do they want to
connect these lines and it's really
really a stretch Donald Trump went out
of his way to say not only that Steve
Bannon uh wasn't a part of a circle but
that he was a loser he went out of his
way to do it
is no easy quick breakup with that and
that's something you're not going to
find out I will tell you that's one of
those examples where you won't find
anywhere and this is the the Trump
consistency right uh incidents you won't
find any why because the left doesn't
want to cover it and of course Steve
Bannon doesn't want to cover it the
right doesn't want to cover it no
because they want to get on Steve
bannon's show I'm just I'm just telling
you exactly you want me to go back to
what was said no it's true if you've got
a problem with what we said it's your
problems with Donald Trump yes your
problem and by the way it's you can have
a problem with Donald Trump it's fine
that's totally fine I think you should
have disagreements with Donald Trump and
I don't think you should condemn anyone
who comes out and says you know I
disagree with Donald Trump on this
that's okay we don't do hero worship or
you could have you could even have a
problem with the fact that Donald Trump
doesn't like Steve Banner but he doesn't
like him he doesn't like him and he has
no respect for him and he's gone out of
his way let me read the quote again
this is overlay r Steve Bennett has
nothing to do with me and my presidency
this is in 2018. when he was fired he
not only lost his job he lost his mind
folks lost his mind Steve was a staffer
who worked for me after I'd already won
the nomination by defeating 17
candidates and he went on later to say
Steve pretends to be at War within me
I'm sorry
if you know the way Trump this is so
brutal yeah Steve pretends to be at war
with the media which he calls the
opposition Purdy that's what he calls it
that's what he calls it yet he spent his
time at the White House leaking false
information to the media to make himself
seem far more important than he was
which was not a lot it was not a lot it
is the only thing that sounds nothing
like it is the only thing he does well
I know what you're doing I know what
you're thinking some things the only
thing
are there other things no
no other things this is the only the
only thing that's the only thing he does
people would say that they would tell me
that's the only that's it really there's
got to be other things he does well it's
the only thing he's ever done well
Steve was rarely in a one-on-one meeting
with me and only pretends to have had
influence to full a few a few people
with no access and no clue
and the final thing with no access and
no clue whom he helped write phony books
oh I love it in other words it could not
be less relevant to Donald Trump for
January 6th I don't give a rat's ass
what Steve Bannon says and by the way I
say this is a guy the only reason any of
you are watching right now or know
anything about me is because of that guy
right there Andrew Breitbart before it
was uh breitbart.com the trademark it
was big Hollywood
and before that even existed I had a
conversation with Andrew Breitbart and
Dennis Miller
so it doesn't bring any joy to it does
kind of just because it's funny the way
that Donald Trump said it but yeah no
you're that's a good question and you
know what this is why I encourage you to
do your own research if it is Donald
Trump taking a steaming crap on someone
who maybe he points out to be a false
conservative or a wolf in sheep's
clothing or someone who we perceive to
be on our side you can't find that
anywhere you can't find it on the left
and the right won't refute it because
they have to play ball too so that's one
that is very easy to yeah and if they
had anybody on the committee that would
push back on this they would bring up
these quotes and be like Oh you mean
this person that he fired in 2018 and
took a giant steaming dump on Oh you
mean Roger Stone who he distanced
himself from in 2015 and says he hasn't
been in communication with him right
these are the people and by the way the
orbit of people can I go back to that
again the three people that are in that
video that's that's almost a Joe Biden
really I get it I understand it was able
to pull that kind of number but still
three people were in the video and to be
clear I don't know Roger Stone at all
I've never spoken with him I don't have
anything against him I don't know one
personally I just know that Donald Trump
fired him in 2015 and he has no bearing
on what Donald Trump did no regarding
January 6th look I would never say it
Roger Stone and his stupid [ __ ] Gomez
Adams should
[Laughter]
you know that I walked up you probably
didn't know there's people I walked up
to me said he said Carter Mia he started
kissing my arms it's weird
right that's what he says I would never
say that Dave said it's off pudding I
said he says that's what he tells me
uh
uh the morning show guy that just lost
his spots why does he even need to be
out there he's like well they're hoping
guys
he's actually taken the bag off his mic
that was there earlier
tree all right move the camera that's
not the Avalon guy it's the other one he
was there the entire morning show was
basically fired and they they were
putting Don Lemon in their place all
right uh let's grab one more chat before
we go to uh to mug Club only and uh
tomorrow by the way there won't be
anything on YouTube there will be a Mud
Club only show though since we're doing
a three-hour stream today he's selling
OxiClean there will be but wait is that
the Noah guy who corrected I can't see
who corrected Don Lemon yes who
corrected that women on climate change I
don't know if that's him but he's
wearing the same shirt you know what
Maybe not maybe he's not have the same
machine the hurricane stranger clothes
yeah
so if you put OxiClean right in the eye
of the hurricane it'll clean up
California him maybe you guys can pull
up the clip where uh uh the the head of
or some representative from Noah
disagreed with Don Lemon live on here
yeah he tried to say is this uh is this
uh it's pretty funny how much of this
hurricane or the intensity has to do
with climate change he was like uh yeah
you shouldn't connect any one event to
climate change but by the way if you
want to laugh uh I know it if you want
to laugh if we have a video about a I
think it was Vox or somebody released
this Tim you you liked it on Twitter
somebody put it in the feed where there
was a sec they were trying to
reintegrate a sex offender into society
hold on let me guess it didn't work no
you got to watch it it's only like it's
hilarious do we have it yeah we do have
it just whatever you want to laugh you
just let me know when we'll pick you
right let's grab a chat first and then
before we go seconds before his
bracelets
he gets five bullets pumped up
I thought it was a I thought it was a
breathalyzer you don't have what stop
blowing into it sir we're gonna let him
walk by this school it should be fine
you don't fondle a Breathless
oh my gosh
yeah every time he gets a thought that
might come out yeah by the way who got
the marks a lot out in Drew Florida
there this is I love that this is what
he uses by the way smeared I know it's
like thanks Noah this is the cheapest
thing I've ever local news has a better
weather shirt than this they gave him an
old TV well by the way Noah has never
been right I did this I want to say back
in 2011 I did uh is Noah smarter than a
fifth grader that's when the Jeff foxy
we literally had two children one was in
sixth grade
I think one was younger uh one I guess
that kid's probably in college now gosh
that's how long I've been doing this
dreams do come true so
um
no we had the kids predict how many
hurricanes there would be just at random
and one of them was closer than Noah
nice that year they never they're not
even within Striking Distance No so at
what point do you say it's useless well
your only job is to help us right to
prepare us for hurricanes but you're
almost always wrong well at least the
CNN guy looks miserable I love that he's
starting to rain again well they're
trying to reintegrate him into society
yes uh it appears as though uh
hurricanes do bring rain
and you can see it yeah I uh they will
not give me an umbrella to make a point
no no they hate me I also hate myself I
mean really I could just do this from a
studio but they'd rather have me catch
pneumonia and I certainly could put my
hair back under my hats but they asked
me to do the Clark Kent just to uh I
need to look disheveled really drive
this home yeah what's that oh hold my
hat okay yes there's zero wind behind
that other guy
this guy is definitely where you don't
want to be yeah right well near him
yeah yeah near the children he has in
that jeep
let's grab one more chat
we'll leave with the sex offender video
you didn't know this was gonna happen
that's a full parking lot
he just he wants to go get some rallies
and just walked out from the Buffalo
Wild Wings like this is a bad day oh no
I thought it was going to go past us all
right one more chat all right Jacob
Scott has question for the crew since it
takes quite a while to walk to the
Capitol from the ellipse ellipse how
could Trump have instigated the people
well what they're saying Donald Trump
was uh you know too far away to have
instigated the Pope the peoples Pope the
pope well Five Mile Walk did you just
say the Pope I no you're hearing things
okay that's right I think the pope
helped I think he said though
you said Pope I said why would you say
patient Pope to me that's why why would
you shake Pope I did look the pope
didn't stop it right he also didn't
release a video well he was busy being
reintegrated into society yeah oh
you just let him run eight Altar Boys
you're like this is not working
they need 12 tasers to take them down
he's on PCP all right do we have that
video yeah I mean that one's obviously
the answer is obvious we've kind of
addressed that here as of course he
couldn't have of course yeah that's kind
of the whole point they're going to
prosecute him all the way up until he
decides to this is all about guilt by
association for all of you and they want
to try and ensure that Donald Trump
doesn't run again because he's the
greatest threat to their Stranglehold on
power that's also why you see some
Republicans who are complicit and by the
way I don't even know how Liz Cheney
considers herself a republican I have no
idea can someone inform me can someone
inform me how Liz Cheney is a republican
now someone like that is a republican
anyone just in name so she can push her
across her Democratic she's a politician
with no office to go to in January thank
God yeah
it was Wyoming tried to throw out the
trash and then some people in The Yards
he said we'll take it we'll take it we
won't so much recycle we'll uh we
consider it landfill they said
oh my God all right so guys we're going
to continue uh taking your questions
here and going into Cassidy Hutchinson
uh on my club their star witness the one
who talked about Donald Trump jerking
the wheel which is of course not true
but we have to be careful because there
are some aspects with her testimony
which they don't know if we're allowed
to actually uh should I say
should I say present a skeptically on
YouTube do we have the video of the sex
offender reintegrating yes all right we
will tomorrow mug Club only we're not
streaming on YouTube uh and uh thank you
so much for being with us the promo code
is Jan 6th 20 off mug Club lottoscar.com
we'll leave you with this and we're
going to Michael
we all out here in this world
and we all got to make it happen it
ain't non-stopping me so like I'm very
confident
[Music]
you achieved sent a picture of his penis
to our producer
[Music]